hey 42 here what took us from living in
caves to being an advanced multilingual
intelligent species it has a lot to do
with just a handful of extremely crucial
inventions let's take a look at the
incredible inventions that played the
biggest part in advancing the human race
first up is fire okay it's not strictly
an invention more a discovery but being
the first source of warmth for humans
its importance cannot go unnoted it's
estimated that fire was discovered 1.8
million years ago and it set the wheels
in motion as it was the basis for energy
for years to cook speaking of wheels
it wasn't until 3500 BC when humans
finally invented the wheel the wheel
proved to be such a crucial component of
the advancement of the human race so why
did it take humans so long to invent it
I mean by 3500 BC it was already the
Bronze Age humans were casting metal
alloys building sailboats and even
complex musical instruments such as the
harp
so what took them so long well the
problem of the wheel was not getting a
cylindrical object to roll on its side
anyone could do that
it was attaching that cylinder to a
stationary platform so it could move
freely and independently without rolling
off down the hill this is known as the
wheel and axle design to achieve this a
lot of factors have to be gotten right
such as the circumference of the axles
has to be perfectly smooth as dust a
hole in the center of the wheel
otherwise there will be too much
friction and the wheels won't turn even
more challenging the axles have to fit
snugly inside the wheel but not too
snugly or they won't rotate freely
inventors would also need access to very
large slabs of wood from a large
tray in order to carve a large wheel
from it the wheel was certainly a huge
challenge all these factors and more is
why humans took so long to invent the
wheel it's not something that would have
just happened overnight and it likely
only happened once but once it was
discovered it spread very quickly over
the rest of Europe
the wheels most likely birthplace was
either Eastern Europe or Mesopotamia but
historians can't quite agree on a
precise location the wheel was so
vitally important because it gave birth
to modern day farming which made us less
nomadic and freed up people's time so
that they could focus on discovering new
inventions imagine you're far out at sea
traveling to a far-off land the ocean
currents are pulling your boat in every
direction you no longer know which way
is north south east or west you have
nothing but your boat to guide you what
happens you will probably end up going
gravely of course or even more likely
just go round and round in circles for
days until you run out of water and diet
see this was what's happened to many a
sailor in the thousands of years between
the invention of the boat and the
navigational device to guide them the
world was full of people getting lost at
sea and the whole thing was a bloody
mess until the 11th century went Han
Dynasty China invented the very first
maritime compass the first compass used
a lodestone which is a naturally
magnetized
iron ore the compass quickly spread
throughout the rest of the world via
maritime contact and so finally people
could safely traverse the seas and
travel far away from their homelands -
distant new worlds opening up new trade
routes and starting the Age of Discovery
it was the desire for knowledge that
took us from being hunter-gatherers to
where we are now
nothing excels the technological
advancement of a species more than the
sharing of knowledge but in the
deme century how would you go about
sharing knowledge there's no internet or
phones so people relied on books but for
many centuries books had to be
painstakingly handwritten one by one
this meant books were very expensive and
knowledge was severely limited for the
majority of the population and for a
long time this proved to be a major
brick wall standing in the way of the
progress of mankind what was really
needed was an abundance of books so
human knowledge could be shared freely
and quickly and that's what the much
needed printing press gave to the human
race when it was invented in the 15th
century although the first movable type
system was created in 11th century Song
Dynasty China the complexity of the
Chinese writing system stopped it from
gaining much traction it wasn't until
the 15th century when Johannes Gutenberg
invented the first Western movable type
printing press in Germany that the idea
of mass printing really caught on
Gutenberg cast individual letters and
punctuation marks out of various metals
which was a vast improvement on the
Chinese system that used wooden blocks
Gutenberg's printing press exponentially
increased the speed at which copies of
books could be made which led to a rapid
increase in the spread of knowledge
across Europe in 1859 a Belgian engineer
called Etienne Lenoir created one of the
most revolutionary pieces of engineering
to date the internal combustion engine
this engineering masterpiece replaced
the dated steam engine to become the de
facto standard for powering the world's
machinery and transportation systems the
internal combustion engine works by
burning fuel in a combustion chamber the
high-pressure gas which is created then
pushes a piston thereby transforming
chemical energy into useful mechanical
energy
the internal combustion engine gave
birth to countless modern technologies
but most notably modern-day cars and
aircraft next up is the telephone
although it's had many pioneers into its
Alexander Graham Bell who was awarded
the first patent for the electric
telephone in 1876 bells goal was to make
a telephone that was affordable to
everyone before this electric
communication such as the electric
telegraph were horrendously expensive
and were only used by the very wealthy
Bell changed this and very soon there
was a telephone in nearly every home
business and learning institution this
enabled instantaneous communication and
revolutionized the way we communicate
with the rest of the world the telephone
catalyzed international business and
accelerated human learning
in later years a telephone system would
also become the building blocks for the
internet next up is the very foundation
that powers the entire world we live in
today
electricity humans have always been
aware of electricity and its power
ancient Egyptian texts dating back to
2,000 750 BC talk about people getting
shots from electric fish such as the
catfish and the electric ray but it
wasn't until Thomas Edison created the
first practical one blasting electric
light bulb in 1879 that electricity
transformed from being just a scientific
curiosity to an essential tool for
modern life following garrisons
invention a whole multitude of other
electrical devices quickly followed in
the years to come
nothing has altered the face of
technology like the discovery and
practical applications of electrical
power in 1928 a Scottish scientist
called Alexander Fleming was
experimenting with bacteria in his lab
were to it when he discovered something
that would change the world he noticed
that one of his petri dishes filled with
bacteria had become contaminated with
mold and everywhere the mold had spread
the bacteria was dead what was this
mysterious mold that had the ability to
stop bacteria dead in its tracks it
turned out to be a fungus called
Penicillium over the next two decades
chemists preferred the fungus and
eventually turned it into the drug
penicillin the world's first antibiotic
penicillin proved to be the magic bullet
for a whole load of previously deadly
diseases
this new miracle cure could fight off
infections without doing any harm to
most humans Fleming's discovery forever
changed the way that we treat diseases
British mathematician and inventor
Charles Babbage invented the first
computer in the year 1832
it contained processes which Babbage
called Mills under memory which he
called the store just like in modern
computers but unfortunately Babbage was
way ahead of his time it wouldn't be
until over a hundred years later in 1971
when the world's first personal computer
was manufactured unsold it was called
the chem back one and sold for 750
dollars ever since then computer
technology has accelerated at an
unprecedented rate and subsequently so
has human knowledge and our
technological accomplishment just like
the abacus did thousands of years ago
the personal computer outsourced the
tasks of complex mathematics and
problem-solving to machines the computer
was so influential to human development
that is accelerated us into a brand new
age the Information Age and finally you
can't talk about the personal computer
without of course talking about the
Internet
no other invention has shaped the way
that we go about our daily lives as much
as the Internet we now heavily rely on
the internet for shopping business
relationships entertainment creativity
and general human communications English
computer scientist Sir Tim berners-lee
invented the world wide web in 1989
whilst working at CERN he then wrote the
very first HTTP web client and server in
1990 berners-lee also founded the World
Wide Web Consortium which is responsible
for maintaining the international
standards for URLs HTTP HTML and CSS or
to put it more simply the technology
that the entire internet runs on we
still use those same standards and
technologies to this day so in a
movement that could be considered both
scary and exciting at the very same time
the internet changed humankind like
nothing before it and as the Internet
and the way that we use it evolves every
year so too does the human race thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you